l'autre grande question c'est bien sûr
l'attitude du modem qui se retrouve en
position d'arbitré dans trente sept
grandes villes de france et 3
arrondissement à paris
à marseille on l'a vu dès hier fois il
ya eu fusion avec la liste ps et dans
d'autres villes la stratégie n'est pas
du tout la même en fait c'est vraiment
du cas par cas en fonction des réalités
locales helen hughes arnaud buste
courtisé sur sa droite comme sur sa
gauche
françois bayrou a finalement tranché le
modem ne donnera aucune consigne
nationale pour le second tour
son président rejette notamment les
appels du pied de l'ump je n'ai eu
aucune négociation d'aucune sorte je
mets d'ailleurs eu aucun appel d'aucune
sorte en provenance notamment de l'ump
et je crois que dans tout ça il ya une
immense part de bluff
l'ump était pourtant prête à lui sauver
la mise à pau où françois bayrou est en
difficulté pour conquérir la mairie
en échange d'un soutien l'ump a exigé un
accord global
françois bayrou a refusé et du coup
d'ailleurs il a paradoxalement refusé
que la question de pau où lui même est
en situation délicate soit abordée avec
l'ump
tout se décide donc au cas par cas ainsi
à marseille le candidat du modem jean
luc bennahmias fait alliance avec le
socialiste jean-noël guérini pour faire
barrage à l'ump jean claude gaudin
j'ai rencontré monsieur gaudin et
monsieur guérini il fait avéré au fur et
à mesure de la journée commence le
programme de monsieur guérini est le
mien et les conditions qu'ils me
faisaient par rapport à l'année pendant
ce du mouvement démocrate dans la future
municipalité la future majorité était
plus favorable à metz et à colombes le
modem fusionne avec l'ump
à quand c'est le retrait sans consigne
de vote à paris bertrand delanoë
privilégie ses alliés verts et rejette
tout partenariat avec le modem des
parisiennes et les parisiens qui ont
voté pour le candidat du mouvement
démocrate dit mon choix s'attendait à
cette voie là ce rassemblement plus
large
il attendait de bertrand delanoë qu'il
soit on va dire à mr d'ouverture et il
s'est comporté comme un candidat
de fermeture du coup marielle de sarnez
maintient ses listes dans les trois
arrondissements où le modem a dépassé
les 10%